[Música]
con nuestra primera invitada del día
vamos a hablar de como las redes
sociales son usadas como medio para
auxiliar a las mujeres cuando se
encuentran en peligro el pasado 2 de
noviembre una joven de 16 años
desapareció en carolina del norte esto
en eeuu la familia denunció el hecho
ante las autoridades que actuaron de
forma rápida pidiendo la colaboración
para dar con su paradero sin embargo no
fue hasta el 4 de noviembre dos días
después reportado su desaparición cuando
la policía recibió una llamada de un
motociclista que denunció que la joven
hizo la famosa señal de socorro viral en
tick tock cuyo significado indica que es
víctima de violencia de género y la
situación no le permite expresar esto
con palabras al momento de la inspección
de este vehículo donde se encontraba y
también interrogar las autoridades se
dieron cuenta identificaron que la
pasajera era esta adolescente
desaparecida algo similar ocurrió una
clínica de barcelona en españa y por
ello quiero hablar entonces y le doy la
bienvenida a nuestro estudio de directo
américa elizabeth castillo hogar
activista feminista elisabeth gracias
por estar aquí con nosotros gracias es
un saludo a la audiencia así es muy buen
día lisa le quiero preguntar entonces
cómo están siendo usadas las redes
sociales para todos estos movimientos y
reportar la violencia contra las mujeres
como han sido de ayuda ahora en esta era
que todo estaba finalizado toda es la
red social que además está coincidiendo
con el encierro que todos estuvimos hace
un año y medio encerrados y encerradas
de manera que se han convertido una
estrategia muy útil para identificar y
para poder buscar ayuda sobre todo yo
creo que el primer aporte que que están
haciendo las redes sociales es poner el
tema porque mucha gente muchas mujeres
por desgracia todavía creen que deben
resistir todo lo que les hagan porque
consideran que eso es parte de la
autoridad del marido y no no es hay que
aprender a decir basta
no lo hacen por miedo a elisabeth además
como ustedes lo decía precisamente con
este encierro estás cuarentenas por
cuenta de la pandemia la violencia
intrafamiliar aumentó sobre todo a las
mujeres y a los niños porque porque el
temor de denunciar al agresor porque hay
un sistema que por desgracia aunque
tenemos sistemas bastante sólidos desde
el punto de vista normativo todo el
proceso de denuncia es muy desgastante
para las víctimas y desafortunadamente
no encuentran una al no encontrar una
respuesta rápida y efectiva se
desestimula la denuncia pero además
porque la impunidad es vergonzosa de
cada caso denunciado a duras penas
logran condenar pues logran dos condenas
de diez casos que se denuncian a duras
penas se consiguen dos condenas y eso
básicamente lo que hace es que las
mujeres no confían en el sistema de
justicia y por eso hay que fortalecer
ese sistema de justicia para que las
denuncias sean atendidas de manera
efectiva y todo el acompañamiento se
puede hacer evitando sobre todo que esto
llegue a feminicidios que es además el
destino al que van muchos casos de
violencia las mujeres ahora también
elizabeth él le quería preguntar viendo
toda esta ola de las redes sociales
invicto y esta famosa seña cuando las
mujeres pueden denunciar que están
siendo maltratadas por parte de un
agresor no es posible que ya esta seña
digamos no tenga efecto o los agresores
estén más pendientes en saber si las
mujeres están siendo están haciendo
algún gesto para prohibir en alguna
manera poder denunciar y decir oye estoy
siendo maltratada necesito ayudas a que
se pueda hacer también cuando se empieza
a identificar esta seña y cuando los
agresores pues por supuesto también la
sepan que otra manera tienen las mujeres
de decir en el con gestos o 'la o alguna
señal que necesitan ayuda en principio
esa es la señal que se está utilizando
pero así no lo pueda hacer en el momento
en el que está solicitando ayuda e
insisto en que el solo hecho de que
entienda que lo que está pasando no es
correcto y que ya tenga la intención de
buscar ayuda cambia muchísimo la
dinámica de la relación violenta cambia
un montón
yo creo que es útil utilizar es útil
buscar la ayuda local eso siempre es
importante muchas mujeres no saben que
por ejemplo en sus ciudades hay redes
completas de atención hay rutas
completas no res rutas completas de
atención para casos de violencia y que
esas rutas empiezan en colombia sería no
con la comisaria de familia solamente
sino que hay espacios a donde pueden
acudir a atender el acompañamiento
jurídico y psicológico que les ayude a
fortalecer el la respuesta a
fortalecerse para parar en la medida de
lo posible sobre todo denunciar los
hechos de violencia porque la
reincidencia elisabeth porque a lo mejor
muchas mujeres cuando pues ya deciden
denunciar vuelven a recaer en este
círculo en este ciclo vicioso de alguna
manera de ser maltratadas como poder
salir realmente de estos casos y abusos
tan terribles contra las mujeres estamos
en una cultura que le enseño a las
mujeres que sin un hombre no son nada
que se tienen que casar que son las
responsables de sostener el hogar que sí
que no importa lo que se tengan que
aguantar con tal de que lo hagan por los
hijos mientras
curso cultural del patriarcado sea tan
fuerte e inti tan insistente las mujeres
van a seguir encontrando que tal vez el
lugar natural es al lado del maltratador
y esto además viene dado en lo que se
denomina una relación de codependencia a
una mujer víctima ya no tienen la
capacidad de tomar las decisiones lo
mismo que una mujer que no ha sufrido
una situación violenta está con un
personaje que además era el que ella
amaba y que todos los días le dice este
sueño de nutrirse no sirve para nada
usted sin mí no es nada y eso va
generando en ella una sensación de
indefensión y de dependencia que por
desgracia es la que causa que vuelva al
hogar pero su no reincidencia al que
reincide es el violento ella no ella
vuelve al espacio porque siente que ese
es su lugar porque por desgracia estamos
en una cultura que le enseño a las
mujeres que tenían que ser ser
responsables del bienestar de sus hijos
por encima del propio bienestar como ven
ahora las nuevas generaciones las
muchachas ya en edad de 12 15 años yo
creo que pues hay un movimiento como de
apertura es el movimiento feminista y
también que pues la gesta les está dando
fuerzas les está diciendo que no se
tienen que aguantar todos esos que
pueden ser independientes que son unos
seres completamente libres que pueden
hacer lo que ellas quieran usted cree
que en un futuro esto pudiera cambiar es
es lo que yo veo pero usted es experta
en esto
a lo mejor no la presión que yo tengo no
puede ser la realidad para donde estamos
dando yo soy un optimista siempre de el
resultado de las movilizaciones sociales
yo creo que ha cambiado como no vamos a
decir que ha cambiado si nos podemos
divorciar en menos de 50 años y votar as
menos de 60 estos últimos 100 años han
sido muy retadores en todo para la
historia humana y las mujeres venimos a
contar una historia en la que estábamos
desaparecidas yo sí creo que hemos
avanzado creo que las nuevas
generaciones tienen posibilidades creo
también que el internet es un reto
poderoso para eliminar la violencia
contra las mujeres porque reviste una
característica que no tienen que no
había tenido hasta ahora la violencia y
es la capacidad de viralizar un mensaje
en cuestión de minutos entonces eso hace
que el acto violento de poner un vídeo
íntimo
una acusación o una denuncia de un
agresor hacia la mujer porque además por
desgracia muchos denuncian a las mujeres
esto es absurdo poner eso en las redes
sociales tiene un impacto de difusión
mucho más alto que impacta directamente
en el bienestar de las mujeres así que
no es sólo el uso del internet para a
favor de la prevención en temas de
violencia sino entender que este nuevo
foro tiene unas dimensiones que pueden
agravar la violencia basada en el género
como la conocemos y el llamadas por
supuesto a no tener miedo a denunciar
hay pues una sociedad que las apoya
completamente elisabeth muchísimas
gracias por su tiempo por estar aquí con
nosotros en directo américa a ustedes
muchas gracias señoras no se dejen
tienen derecho